the birds the birds have just gone crazy
you can hear them chirping yeah the
environmental impact of code fit has
been that the world is regenerated where
I get to call we didn't maybe yelled I
write a lot of us are appreciating to be
from the country that we are from muji
frustrating and disappointing
strange strange very strange personally
I would feel safer in China than I would
somewhere like the states I don't want
my country to be associated with the
current leader the world now takes life
way way more seriously
yeah I think the world has really
changed since covered 19 and I believe
that it's yeah definitely will lead to
my isolation during the next year's it's
tough for foreigners to come back into
the country just because people are
still extremely worried we've had a
really low incident of people getting
the illness here so if we get an influx
of tourists because we live in a tourist
location we get an influx of tourists
and they're not monitored and then
object the risk to us as the locals is
absolutely massively busy I see the
height of summer I think after the
pandemic New Zealand will still really
remain open to the idea of foreigners
but I think realistically you know our
borders might have to be closed for a
bit longer to protect us here the air is
a lot cleaner I noticed during lockdown
and with quite a clean capturing anyhow
so this is quite good to see
[Music]
pollution has become so much less than
Delhi is one of the most polluted cities
in the world all you are Kira you know
Rina the sky is bluer there's no waste
and the birds the bridge has just gone
crazy after you can hear them chopping
there's the coil bird
that's the coil
the environmental impact of Copan has
been that the world is regenerate if
you've seen it with the dolphins in the
bays in Italy and our seas are very blue
but they are even bluer we see the stars
at night because there isn't the solar
glare anymore and I would just really
hope that people get the message of how
fast the world can regenerate when we
leave it alone then take a look at the
reverse of the calmness to do today
spend millions of rupees and decreasing
the deep polluting the Ganges and it'll
just become clear with two weeks of
lockdown I just wonder what's going to
happen once the lobster leaves and we're
back to our polluting tendencies when we
started going into self-isolation
ourselves about three months ago I was
thinking hey you know they're already
used should stay at their place right
don't go out try to you know do the best
you can and we'll figure this out
but in reality you know not everybody
can do it so many developing countries
my own country already we don't have
that luxury might take a little walk
[Music]
there's people who leave by the day a
lot of people leave but you know
whatever you sail on that they give you
if you got a good sail you eat else you
don't right so for those people they say
it's a pretty tough like my my right is
your I died I died I defer starvation or
I get the coal Peter maybe he'll die
being from Australia I think I feel like
a majority of Australians feel very
thankful for the country that we live in
politicians hadn't really had a lot of
backing from from the country prior to
covert 19 but they seem to have done
such a great job that there's a lot of
reception for that and I think a lot of
us are appreciating to be from the
country that we are from I never I knew
and I never expected the authorities to
take a proper care of people when the
pandemic was just around the corner when
it all started - my opinion I was right
and there were so many days when I read
the news like I felt despair
[Music]
it's been a game of politics and
bickering rather than actually solving
issues so it's been hugely frustrating
and disappointing that there has been a
lack of global leadership on this in a
very very big way we will see if Trump
is going to be re-elected or not I think
that he didn't do a good job so it might
have been not completely wrong to try to
keep the arm or to open up the economy
again fast but yeah there were too many
people infected beforehand so to take
hydroxychloroquine himself even though
he wasn't infected yeah
strange strange very strange and
personally I would feel safer in China
than I would somewhere like the states
just looking at how they dealt with the
corona outbreak in such a frightening ly
efficient way I mean it's a bit 1984 but
it's it's incredible
my view of the United States in China or
other countries in general haven't
changed pretty much the same maybe
because I don't quite associate the
countries with their leaders I don't
want my country to be associated with
the current leader I feel very very
sorry for the politicians I think
they've got a really really difficult
task nobody's actually got a clue
because nobody's been in this situation
before the world is becoming one we are
all getting closer even though we are
really far far away from each other
because again the world now takes life
way way more seriously that's my view
about how this whole situation has
changed us
you
you